this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armies museum in the uk
a museum that houses a collection of
thousands of iconic arms and armor
from throughout history on today's
episode he's going to be breaking down
the guns of cyberpunk 2077 to see what
real world weapons inspired the sci-fi
creations in the game
the bit they've definitely taken is the
what's affectionately known as the hk
slap like that let us know if there are
any other games guns and mechanics that
you want to see on the show
and make sure to subscribe for more
videos like this such as our recent
escape from tarkov episode
and if you want to support jonathan's
work at the royal army's museum check
out the links in the description of this
video
right time to hit the streets of night
city
sauvi are you
willing
okay i'm gonna invoke the new
catchphrase and pause
just wanna say about the pistol
it's a machine pistol so or a fully
automatic pistol and it's kind of
chugging along at a very very slow rate
of fire
a bolt of that size and mass propelled
by any kind of cartridge that propels a
bullet worth a dam
is going to send that bolt flying back
and forth at a much higher rate so
machine pistols like this
typically more than a thousand rounds
per minute
and this thing's chugging along at i
don't know three or four hundred
we've also got an interesting ejection
pattern for the
cartridge empty cartridge cases uh the
ejection is going
straight up now in a first person
shooter first person rpg type setting
that's quite distracting and detracts
from your ability to
aim in real life it's really not a
problem things that eject
vertically include the luger pistol
which can land hot cartridge cases in
your hair
and the scorpion machine pistols flash
submachine gun tends to eject
violently straight up so it's not
unheard of
interesting to me when um things are
happening games
that are a problem aren't actually a
problem in real life so i think
perfectly serviceable near future
handgun
it's maybe a bit big and bulky in the
current era for guns to carry around
they're quite compact this is more like
a this is bigger than like a
service handgun for an armed force just
quickly on the sites
they're very conventional they really
look like current night sights so
they're glowing so
you can pick them up in low light
they're not doing anything particularly
sci-fi
i imagine they're upgradeable so that
they are more sci-fi
ladies and gentlemen jackie wells
okay i'm gonna pause there right we've
got a new weapon to me anyway
it's i believe it's a submachine gun in
the game but the the
depth of the magazine front to back
suggests that's probably
an assault rifle or perhaps something
like the p90 cartridge which is quite
long to be fair
so hey the game says machine gun who am
i to argue it's a
bullpup so we've got working parts
behind the trigger
it's like an uber bullpup in that
the magazine is attached right at the
back of the receiver uh which at first
glance
has you scratching your head or thinking
that's impossible it's actually not
impossible
um there is one firearm and one firearm
only that i know of
that resembles this configuration which
is the tkb-022 which is a russian
prototype bullpup and it has the
magazine right at the back
of the gun as well now that's because
it's got a
vertically sliding breech block so the
bolt goes
up and down to feed rounds into the
chamber now i don't know if the
developers what got us so far as to
think
how the action of the gun works and
whether what they've designed makes any
logical sense
no reason why they would have to do that
it's fiction after all but technically a
very interesting design
so in this it's a ballpark and it has a
trigger shaped cocking handle on the top
and a sort of carrying handle on the top
it does resemble our old friend the fam
ass
here is the fam ass a product of the
1970s as we have explained
in previous videos so this this was
always a very sci-fi looking gun
so i dare say there is some inspiration
with this weapon
for people who aren't intimately
familiar with firearms um you could
stick this in a game as is
in an inner science fiction shooter and
a lot of people would assume it was a
gun from the future i think
but then i am getting older
all right i just want to pause there to
say this thing is
pretty cool so what we've got here is as
you can tell
and people already playing it will
already know is a
apparently 12 gauge shotgun but it's
using
electromagnetic technology to accelerate
whatever it's shooting and i imagine
there's a choice of buckshot
slug different different ammunition
that's what it appears to be anyway so a
rail railgun shotgun
effectively the the aesthetic of it is
almost like the super shotgun
and the bfg from doom kind of
smashed together which i very much enjoy
but then when we open it up we've got a
conventional top brake lever and we've
got conventional looking
brass or copper case heads there the
charging up effect
fits that meme of the double barrel
shotgun as a devastating close range
weapon
now i knew this was coming so i've
grabbed a gun
to show you i've gone for what i think
we would probably call
a howder pistol two triggers for the two
hammers so it's mechanically very simple
so an old an old idea this would
be a very serviceable close combat
weapon just as we see
on screen major difference i suppose is
this saw handle
it allows uh recoil control because
something like this especially if you're
going to try and pull two triggers at
the same time which you can do with this
means a lot of recoil which tends to tip
up
so this stops the gun from pivoting
upwards and out of your hand perhaps
yeah so a really interesting historic
firearm that i
just thought people might want to see
pause right um so i was confused by the
submachine gun that looked more like an
assault rifle and now we have an assault
rifle that looks
more like a submachine gun this though
this is like a vector
mashed up with a galil um the the
israeli galil family of rifles that
that hand guard with the big hand stop
at the rear
is reminiscent of the one on the ace and
actually on a couple of the earlier
variants now as a museum we don't always
have the latest
versions of things so we don't have the
ace
uh we have a couple of the other short
alleles so this is a
compact galil not not the ac as i say
i've also grabbed it because as well as
having
some of the styling cues referenced in
this design because it's got this
knuckle bow trigger guard
that always makes things look more
sci-fi some of the guns are clearly
meant to use
a lot of polymer in their design this is
quite
quite an 80s looking gun we've got a
what appears to be a
stamped steel receiver which is very
much 60 70s 80s technology but we have
some
very futuristic curves and
greebly's on there that make it look
more sci-fi
we've got another handgun a revolving
pistol
as they might have said in the 19th
century and it is interesting that
revolvers
never seem to go away entirely they go
out of they've gone out of fashion
largely because of the low capacity
that's always offset
in pop culture by you only get five or
six shots but those shots are more
powerful
because you can fit a bigger cartridge
in the gun the gun can
take the explosion that's happening
inside without flying apart
so does a revolver make sense as much
sense as a lot of things
in the game do it's um it's fiction
after all what i i like the design
it's got the alien style round counter
by the look of it
it's got more what i was expecting for
future sites equivalent of iron sights
but they appear to be
projected or are on a very slim bit of
um
screen or something but that you've got
like a crosshair reticle
floats in midair above your gun that's
what you want that's where we will be
going
i've managed to miss there how this
thing is actually reloading and it's a
bit
wacky we've got a version here of the
top brake design which goes back to the
19th century
we've moved away from that in in
revolver design because it makes the gun
weaker
it's breaking the frame open to allow
the empty
cylinder to come out and another one to
be pushed in and then you have to slap
the top of the gun
down almost like the top cover on a
machine gun
very inefficient and slow good for
gameplay
balance because it means your gun takes
longer to reload and you only get your
limited number of shots but it doesn't
make much sense as a
viable design
i'm gonna pause there obviously a
futuristic assault rifle
it's it's a bit of a mashup of different
features so it has a
has one very obvious feature that we'll
deal with right away this is an akm
and the the rough curvature and
configuration of the magazine is clearly
inspired by
the ak and its derivatives but obviously
this isn't this is by no means a
futuristic ak that we have in front of
us
at the rear we've got features very
reminiscent of
a modern ar-15 uh just a few
sort of extrapolated features from
different designs i think the
the handguard front hand guard almost
looks a little bit sa-80 i know that the
original
pen and paper game had as one of its
futuristic weapons just an sa-80 with a
different name
so maybe that's a callback to the school
game the sort of the bulk of the res
of the gun being sort of front heavy
gives it quite a distinctive look
now whether whether the back of the gun
actually has enough space for a firing
mechanism to to work within is a little
unclear it looks a little bit stubby at
the back
most of that seems to be stock but um
don't know it's the future
i don't know how these things work yet
what we also see is the
reloading technique where you take a
fresh magazine and you you
slap the magazine catch push out the
empty and then rock in
your new magazine the reason that
technique was developed is because that
magazine system is quite slow to reload
very secure
you know when the magazine is on the gun
it's not going to drop out but
it doesn't beat pressing a button to
drop the magazine out and having another
one ready to push in
so it's surprising that a future weapon
would use this
arguably antiquated system
another submachine gun quite an unusual
looking design from the first person
view but i can see from the um
the hud what it's taking its inspiration
from at least partly
looking rather a lot like sci-fi up ump
hecarim [ __ ] ump um so resembling
the weapon the bit they've definitely
taken is the
what's affectionately known as the hk
slap so with the
uh the bolt locked open in this position
pretty much
as well as we see here and we see not
not the open hand
slap the cocking handle but neo's
um closed fist approach from the matrix
like that which looks cool and
does the job the that hk slap is
actually in the manual for the mp5
there's a lot of
debate over whether you should or
shouldn't do it the german german armed
forces trained that you should not do it
but
h k themselves say that you should
speaking of style points we have we have
what's now become known as the wick
flick
so we we press the magazine release
can't really do with the real ump
because it doesn't have a button as a
paddle
and then we flick the gun off to the
right and the magazine goes flying out
you've seen it in the movies
and then you bring it back to the other
side to put the next magazine in
in theory it's if in case a magazine
sticks in the gun
and prevents you very rapidly reloading
you flick the gun
often done for style points i suspect
we're on to uh something i've just seen
is called the crusher
why not to shotgun it needs a silly
macho name this is like
this is reminiscent of some real world
riot or close quarters to combat or even
door breaching shotguns that are super
short
the design of the receiver is typical of
a modern self-loading shotgun
some of them anyway you've got a cocking
handle on the left-hand side we've got a
big
chunky polymer magazine that's yellow
which
normally would denote some sort of less
lethal thing
the famously yellow less lethal gun is
is the taser shotgun which
um we don't see anymore it's quite hard
to dress up a shotgun to make it look
sci-fi so i think they've done a good
job here
uh let's see how it works oh
i'm gonna have to pause there good grief
uh we've just seen
and i think in in popular culture this
is why partly why shotguns are
a thing more than they are in real world
for fighting people with we have this
perception that they will
take off a limb which is what we just
saw there in reality the reality is
both less horrific and more horrific
than that
in that you cannot cleanly sever a limb
with a firearm it will
it will do horrific damage to human
tissue that we won't go into
but it would not work as we see there
of course we've got here the idea of the
smart
bullet and it's a guided projectile this
is something that doesn't
exist in use but um about 10 years ago
darpa in america did produce a steerable
50 caliber bullet which had inflatable
rings on it
in order to change air resistance and
turn the bullet we've of course seen
this in various science fiction
properties as well
hit your target and fire over cover and
the projectile steers itself to the
target i don't know if that will ever
become a
reality for combat infantry it's not too
far a leap to suggest that's a steerable
under-barrel missile there is there is
in fact a prototype out there
of exactly that now that hasn't gone in
anywhere yet that doesn't mean that it
won't in the future
the the computer's tracking systems now
are sophisticated enough already to
track a moving target so we're already
somewhat on the way to this type of
technology but it's a way off
in the way that it's depicted here but
uh really adds to gameplay opportunities
of course when you can
hide behind cover and shoot someone
behind cover as well perhaps
thanks everyone for watching um this has
been a lot of fun if you'd like to
make a donation to the museum so that we
can carry on
doing this collaboration and caring for
the collection that we have here
it's not expected in any way but some
people have responded already and we're
really grateful for that
especially the chap who said he'd like
to buy me a beer we'll take the donation
instead
that's great thank you um if you'd even
like to consider becoming a member
there's a link for that in the
description as well so
have a look at those but either way
thanks again for watching we really
appreciate it
[Music]
you